billy connolly mrs brown was that that
was your first big acting break wasn't
it
yeah and is it because of that movie
that you got invited to have dinner with
the queen
no that was a because i was friendly
with fergie at the time
that dates this story
and obviously you have to be on your
best behavior don't you have a
particular trick that you do
is it a dinner party to do it or is it
buffets or what
oh yeah the thing it's not a buffet it
was a thing
myself and some actor friends did at
edinburgh festival many years ago
it hadn't been a festival you're often
asked to these
buffets with the lord mayor and people
like that and
they give you the paper plates and those
tomatoes and bits and stuff and a
plastic fork
and a drink so you can't do anything
with either those
there's no way you put the drink down in
your tomatoes keep rolling around
it becomes one of those little things
you used to get to put
ball bearings in mickey mouse's eyes
[Music]
so here's what you do if you're ever at
one of those buffets it's the best the
only thing you can do
is you put your willy on the plate
and then you get some salad
i put it on the top don't put dressing
on
no you mustn't make a big mountain of it
that's true you just do enough so to
look as there's something lurking in the
long run
and then and then you just walk along
and
mingle with people hello
and then you daily you dare each other
to talk go and talk to the lord mayor's
wife
talk about salad and they do a lovely
salad
and you can see the women going i didn't
see the sausage rolls
beware because those white plastic forks
very sharp you'll be pissing like a
fountain
[Applause]
and kevin i was saying the introduction
i mean your success is extraordinary now
you know
i'm sitting beside the guy that's pulled
on three and a half billion dollars
my success has been all right
i'm sorry to bring you down you walk
down here high as a kite
and that's like but no but you must get
soft on the streets and stuff like that
now
aye usually by people collecting for
charities
i asked to sign 25 copies
uh 25 pirate copies
of my own dvd
can you understand anything kevin i said
no
i got something about balls at the end
is that what
yeah he said balls yeah he did say no
can you seriously not
understand not very much i was going to
kind of question him as he was going
along but
actually tried the show in america than
one gig
a guy complimented me approached me
after the set
and he goes hey man are you actually
scottish
and i said yes and it goes [__] man your
english is pretty good
because james now scottish phrases have
you taught because you've worked with
jessica a lot have you taught her any
scottish phrases or i don't think i've
taught her too much but i remember
sitting here on this couch a while ago
with them
uh i was about to say dame metal street
but she's not a dame no
you should be you're right american yeah
american game called meadow street
and uh and i tried a scottish phrasing
or to see if you could understand what i
was saying so i'll try it on
okay oh yeah all right this place is
pure hoaching me ball bags
it's hot this place is pure hoaching my
ball bags
this place is pier ho chi minh balbans
yeah but what does it mean
it means that this place
is making your balls feel
this place is full of egypt or idiots
oh not very nice to say that
you said it to merle street yeah
was it was it robert redford who was
very keen on your english accent
oh so yeah i'm playing an american in
this uh film with robert redford and
i uh i'm playing an american but i don't
stay in the american accent in between
takes and stuff i find that quite
annoying for some reason so
i i go up to him and i'm like here
here's the thing in blah blah and what
do you think i should do this so i think
you should do that and he'd be like whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa do the american
accent i was like
i can't express myself properly if i'm
like coming if i'm acting in between
takes
he says well can you do an english
accent in between tips then i know
i know and i'm like it's robert redford
uh you've kind of got to do it yeah
but why do you want to do an english
accent because he could understand that
and he couldn't understand mine
tell
kind of that one i mean awful as it is
it sort of makes sense
this next one was the cameraman's blind
what
you don't know anything you know i don't
know nobody gives you a book to say this
is how you become an actor this is what
you do
you're just an idiot you know drinking
lager and having curry and people say
now you're an actor did you send those
pictures out to people no they were
nothing to do with me that was a it was
it was a it was a popular daily
newspaper
oh so they were published yes
i just assumed that was you trying to be
more i don't know
they were published published obviously
i was a style icon
because alan obviously theater very
important to you cabaret brought you to
america
and all these amazing things because how
many times did you do cabaret in the end
oh three i did it in london with jane
horrocks actually
who's playing the part that you played
oh [__]
and kyle jones oh i love it i must see
that and it's so funny i said to jane
you know 26 years ago she was my sexy
co-star in cabaret now she's my mom and
a dustbin
that's the acting industry for a lady
but i did it in london and then i did it
on broadway and then i did it again on
broadway
just a few years ago then i went back
and did it again just to
work before i die and which time did you
have the thing where it was really hot
do you know the story i'm talking about
it was hot uh
do you oh well well when i got hit on
the head yes
that was the first time on broadway oh
so what happened was i was
uh i was going to do a film so i've gone
to la for a costume fitting
and i came back and my you know on the
plane you get all funny your
tubes to get all funny so i did a neti
pot you know that little thing you put
salty water in a thing and you go up
like this and it goes up your nose and
goes you know that thing yeah
and then so it's a it's like a thing to
clean up your tubes okay
uh with salty water kosher salt actually
shout out to the juice that's good
and uh so i was uh doing the show that
night and i'm sort of lounging
provocatively you know on the top of the
thing
and you know like when surfers get that
surface drip thing
an hour after surfing suddenly this
stuff gushes out well i'm just lounge
like that and all of a sudden a gush of
water just comes out my nose and down my
bare chest and i'm like wow not so sexy
now
so i kind of you know anvil over to the
side of the stage
and blew my nose and then and then i
had to get down the stairs and back to
them to the play and
because it was a different route that i
was taking because i was now off the
side i ran
right into a light a big huge uh light
and
it went i made this huge divot in my
head and then
for the rest of the first half i was
getting more and more
woozy and i'd go to open a door in my
hand i couldn't find the handle
and i'd be like sunny balls
and then what was hilarious at the
interval i went up i collapsed and i
went out of my dressing room collapsed
and the stage manager came up to my room
and stood over me like this and went
alan do you think you'll be able to do
this
oh i have to go to the hospital so
then and so there were all these people
suddenly were in my room they're all
freaking out you know
and i had to go to the hospital and
they're trying to get my clothes off
dinner and i
and i was just because i at the end of
the first act i had a swastika on my bum
and i lifted up my
coat and that was at the spotlight on my
cheek and that was the end of the first
like symbolize the rise of you know
fascism and
uh and um my bum was a conduit
and it's been a conden for a lot of
things
uh cheers uh so anyway i was like
they're also getting quicker in the car
so you've got to go to the hospital
and i was just getting wet wipes and
going like this and like what you're
doing i said well
the doctor might be jewish and i'd be
angry
and uh and then i got to the hospital
and it was indeed a very hot night it
was a summer night
and um i was all like i got tubes in me
and wires and everything
and there was a lady who'd been in the
audience had fainted
with heat stroke and was taken to the
hospital and was in the next room
to me in that same hospital wow and so
they came in and i was like mask one
said
allen's a lady next door and she was
fainting and you know blah blah would
you go in and say hello
and so anyway i heard them and i'm in my
trolley in my little you know
stretcher on wheels what do you got and
with tubes and everything
and i heard him go you know how you're
so sad you were so excited to go and see
alan coming and she goes oh i waited for
months for my ticket i can't believe i
missed seeing him
and they went well here
are you and have you done the zero
gravity thing with your brother
no i've been in a plane with my brother
my brother was a fighter pilot in the
raf
and he took me up he flew tornadoes and
uh i managed to get a backseat
trip in a tornado with him which was
extraordinary
just because i never i'd know you know i
never seen him at his work and there i
could see just down the side i could see
a bit of his helmet i guess and um he
took we did a lap of scotland in about
an hour and a half
and it was extraordinary but it's
horribly um
it makes you so sick it made me very
sick anyway
and i think he probably was desperately
trying to make me very sick as well
i didn't pass out no i just puked the
most the most humiliating part for me
was when we la when we got back
because you have to get helped out of
those airplanes then and there's a
ground crew that come up on a ladder
and and you have to pass them your bag
of puke
[Laughter]
you would think having uh lots of
children would keep you kind of young
tech savvy you know you'd know what's
going on but david tennant this has not
happened for you
you recently found out that you got left
behind in
the world of texting and things well
yeah
i was now when you start jobs there's a
because of the metoo movement and lots
of you know
great strides forward are being made in
making sure workplaces are safe
so so now different companies have
different ways of coping with that and i
was i had to for a show i was doing i
had to sit and watch a video and prove
that i'd watch this video from start to
finish
and it very takes you through things
that are acceptable and not acceptable
in the workplace
and then right at the end of this
sequence
when it's talking about how to
communicate uh on your mobile phone and
what's appropriate and what isn't
appropriate
it says and remember the eggplant emoji
is not just an eggplant
and that's it i'm left going what the
[__] is it it's an aubergine right i
mean
it's but that's not what they mean
there's a hole and it turns out and i i
knew nothing about this there's a whole
kind of language yes there is
usually based around foodstuffs
where they represent other things
yes asking someone out for a taco could
easily be misinterpreted
it turns out did you know that
be careful did you know about this yes
of course
i mean the eggplant kind of looks like
it doesn't even look like an eggplant
it's it's you know
and then you've got the peach and then
if you if you start adding to that the
rain drops and all you can do anything
it's always innocent
clearly but do you text do you have a
smartphone
i do yes okay then i have no idea how
that passed you by that's
weird because because i thought the
emojis were just meant to represent what
they represented i didn't know
it was this whole kind of other language
you had to learn
can you get explicit that's what we need
yes apple needs to move forward and just
call
a vagina a vagina
what is that
and now you look very nice but i thought
you know you're a scot i thought you
might be sporting you know the kilt on
the red carpet
no no do you ever do the kilt oh yeah
i've done the kill i've done the kick
not in the red carpet no i don't think
you should do it yeah maybe i should
i love people are going yes you have
in glasgow oh i did
hey do you want to answer these
questions for me by the way this this
i mean basically did you move to america
she's from scotland but
but just goes wherever wherever i go
yes better than i do so if i'm saying
anything wrong
you keep me in line apparently she will
yeah
minutes into the show yes you have
so maybe i i wore a a kilt at my
sister's wedding though
in in paisley scotland and
i had to go up and do a reading and and
my mother and the family were in the
front row
and of course as you know in scotland
there's a certain rule to wearing the
kilts and you know i'm sitting like this
everybody's kneeling forward you know
and my mom is
is looking at me she's doing this and
she's going
i think that she's telling me to pray
the whole congregation is watching me so
i'm like listen i'm looking out and i'm
like
and
and then i realized that everybody is
staring right oh
and i'm like this is not going to go
and that's why i always forget that i've
worn kills
it's always a disaster
you